the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
the second carbohydrate-based synthetic
pathway we're going to look at is called
gluconeogenesis gluconeogenesis is the
synthesis of glucose from non
carbohydrate precursors let's look at
panel a of this storyboard storyboard 31
there are some organs in the body that
require glucose as their metabolic fuel
yet they don't have the capacity to make
it or to make much of it
examples are the brain renal medulla red
blood cells and the testes to give an
idea of the scale of the problem the
body faces we only have about 200 grams
of glucose or glycogen stored away in
our body and the brain alone uses more
than half of that each day so we don't
have much in the way of a carbohydrate
reserve the body compensates by having
certain organs specifically the liver
and renal cortex act as specialized
manufacturing centers to produce an
export glucose the chemical raw
materials they use include organic acids
such as lactate some amino acids and the
three carbon residues from odd chain
fatty acids that enter catabolism to get
an idea of how gluconeogenesis works
let's take a look at the box here at the
bottom of panel a you see a muscle
working very hard as evidenced by the
fact that it's secreting lactate out
into the blood the lactate travels from
the working muscle by the blood to the
liver where the lactate is taken in the
pathway of gluconeogenesis with energy
and reducing equivalent input rebuilds
glucose from that lactate precursor the
glucose is then sent back out into the
blood returns to the muscle enabling the
muscle to continue hard work as I've
described earlier in 507 this functional
relationship between a muscle and the
liver is called the Cori cycle let's
look at panel B depending on how you
look at it there are seven or
we ate non carbohydrate precursors to
glucose in gluconeogenesis they're
listed in this panel and I've indicated
these precursors by numbers one through
eight the first seven are not
carbohydrates so they qualify as non
carbohydrate precursors as fits the
definition for a gluconeogenic compound
the eighth is actually a carbohydrate
it's ribose
I'm semi illegally squeezing it in here
because ribose acts as a major
gluconeogenic precursor by way of the
pentose phosphate pathway or PPP we
haven't covered the pentose phosphate
pathway yet but we'll see when we do
cover it exactly how this pathway works
to manufacture glucose in other words
ribose from the diet can be converted
into glucose by way of the pentose
phosphate pathway coupled to
gluconeogenesis a little bit later in
this lecture we'll see how each of these
precursors that is numbers 1 through 8
are converted to glucose by the pathway
of gluconeogenesis the best way to start
thinking about gluconeogenesis is to
think of it as glycolysis running in
Reverse as shown here in panels see
glycolysis is conversion of glucose
ultimately to pyruvate as we know that
pathway goes with the net generation of
ATP that is it is exergonic accordingly
if we go from pyruvate back to glucose
we know that in order to make that
reverse pathway exergonic we're going to
need to have energy input as we learned
earlier there are 10 steps in glycolysis
going from glucose to pyruvate three of
those steps are thermodynamically
irreversible those are the steps that
commit molecules to flow from left to
right as drawn in this panel the
thermodynamically irreversible steps of
glycolysis our first hexyl kinase
glucokinase that is the conversion of
glucose to glucose 6-phosphate the
secondary reversible step is
phosphofructokinase 1 the conversion of
fructose 6-phosphate to fructose 1 6
bisphosphate the third irreversible step
is pyruvate kinase the conversion of
phospho enol pyruvate to pyruvate we
have to find a way in gluconeogenesis to
bypass these three thermodynamically
irreversible steps the enzymes that were
in
to circumvent the three
thermodynamically irreversible steps of
glycolysis are shown in green asterisks
in this panel for example
glucose-6-phosphatase hydrolyzes the six
phosphate from glucose 6-phosphate
converting it to glucose a second
asterisked enzyme of gluconeogenesis is
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate a's which
converts fructose 1 6 bisphosphate by
hydrolysis to fructose 6-phosphate the
third irreversible step that we need to
bypass is pyruvate kinase 2 enzymes were
invented to enable this bypass pyruvate
carboxylase which we have studied before
in several contexts in 507 and a new
enzyme phosphoenolpyruvate carboxykinase
or pepsi k pyruvate carboxylase and
pepsi k work in a partnership with
several other enzymes actually in a mini
pathway to bypass the pyruvate kinase
step of glycolysis and hence enabled
gluconeogenesis lastly at the right of
this panel is a large inverted L this is
meant to symbolize the eight precursors
to gluconeogenesis these precursors will
enter the gluconeogenic pathway and flow
by the hatched arrow lines all the way
up to glucose this network of reactions
allows the conversion of molecules such
as the amino acid glutamate all the way
to glucose now we're going to turn to
storyboard 32 let's look at panel a and
let's start out by looking at the
mechanisms by which the four key enzymes
of gluconeogenesis works the first two
enzymes glucose-6-phosphatase and
glucose 1 6 bisphosphate a's carry out
simple phosphate ester hydrolysis as
shown the third enzyme is pyruvate
carboxylase we looked at this enzyme
mechanistically back in the fatty acid
catabolism lectures when I taught about
the mechanisms by which co2 can be
captured and added to an organic acid
pyruvate carboxylase will convert
pyruvate to oxaloacetate hence it's an
an applaud again xym that helps maintain
the levels of TCA intermediates in the
cases we've looked at so far
PC helps maintain specifically
oxaloacetate levels refer back to the
lecture on
box laces to see how this enzyme works
from a mechanistic perspective now let's
look at panel be the last and fourth key
enzyme I want to discuss in
gluconeogenesis is phosphoenolpyruvate
carboxykinase or pepsi k we haven't seen
an enzyme that works like this before so
let me go through its mechanism in some
detail pepsi k is going to convert
oxaloacetate to phosphoenolpyruvate the
enzyme is active in the liver and renal
cortex under physiological conditions
that mandate gluconeogenesis be turned
on the enzyme takes oxaloacetate which
as we know is a beta keto acid thus it's
prone to decarboxylation when co2 is
removed from oxaloacetate you get a
transient pyruvate enolate which is an
anion the oxygen anion of the pyruvate
enolate will attack the gamma phosphate
that is the terminal phosphate of GTP
and thus the pyruvate enolate will
become phosphorylated the product of
phosphorylation is phospho enol pyruvate
or PEP
hence the concerted action of two
enzymes pyruvate carboxylase and pepsi k
enables reversal of the otherwise
irreversible PK step that pyruvate
kinase step and allows the cell to do
gluconeogenesis let's look now at panel
C now that we've seen the identities of
the eight precursors to glucose in
gluconeogenesis and we've done a little
bit of learning about the mechanisms of
some of the key enzymes in the pathway
we can turn our attention to a network
analysis of the overall gluconeogenic
pathway the pathway in this panel may
seem a bit daunting because it's pretty
much everything we've learned about
metabolism so far in 507 so let's go
through it slowly in little pieces let's
start over on the Left where the glucose
molecule is situated in a squiggly box
note that the glucose in the squiggly
box is being set out of the cell that is
it's going in the opposite direction
from the direction in which we've dealt
with glucose so far and metabolism
usually we think of glucose as coming
into the cell and entering metabolism
this is a liver cell or renal cortex
cell that's in the process of manual
action glucose from those eight
precursors the ones I mentioned above
and sending the manufactured glucose out
into the blood in this metabolic map the
hatched lines that is the lines that
look like railroad tracks represent the
gluconeogenic pathways now let's start
walking through the metabolic map
slightly to the right of the middle of
the diagram you'll see the amino acid
alanine and the three carbon organic
acid lactate lactate is precursor number
one in my scheme the numbering again is
in panel B of the previous storyboard
and alanine is precursor at number two
let's start with lactate lactate would
typically come into the liver from the
blood perhaps from a working muscle
think about the quarry cycle for a
moment lactate dehydrogenase will
convert the lactate into pyruvate in the
liver or in the renal cortex in the
other gluconeogenic organ let's look
next at alanine alanine gluconeogenic
precursor number two is of course an
amino acid and a PLP mediated reaction
will convert it to pyruvate that
reactions involves specifically the loss
of alanines amino group now imagine the
resulting pyruvate that is from either
lactate or alanine translocating to the
right into the mitochondrion words
carboxylated by pyruvate carboxylase
into oxaloacetate this is the reaction
mechanism we looked at a short time ago
now remember that malate dehydrogenase
or mdh thermodynamically favors the
formation of malate from oxaloacetate so
our two molecules navigating the
gluconeogenic pathway that is precursors
one and two transit from oxaloacetate
into malate malate is in the
mitochondrion at this point and in the
next step it exits the mitochondrion and
goes into the cytosol as I've mentioned
before the transporter for malate works
in both directions malate now
transported into the cytosol can be
converted back to oxaloacetate by the
cytoplasmic version of malate
dehydrogenase the oxaloacetate thus
produced in the cytosol goes upward
following the vertical arrow
lastly Pepsi que la serena pyruvate
carboxylase
AAS converts the oxaloacetate into
cytoplasmic phosphoenolpyruvate let's
pause here for a minute and review look
at where phosphoenolpyruvate is on the
metabolic map and then look to the right
on the right you'll see pyruvate on the
rightward side of the one-way arrow you
will also see lactate and alanine
molecules 1 & 2 respectively having
their carbons flow into the pool of
pyruvate the pyruvate pool which starts
in the cytosol get shuttled into the
mitochondrion where pyruvate carboxylase
converts the molecules derived from
pyruvate that is lactate and alanine
into mitochondrial oxaloacetate then the
mitochondrial pool is converted from
oxaloacetate into malate which exits the
mitochondrion and the molecules now
represent a malate pool that's in the
cytosol that malate pool which began as
pyruvate alanine and lactate is
converted to oxaloacetate and lastly our
new enzyme Pepsi K converts the
oxaloacetate into cytoplasmic
phosphoenolpyruvate all of this was done
in order to bypass the one-way step
between fossil enol pyruvate and
pyruvate in other words I can go from
fostro enol pyruvate to pyruvate quite
easily by pyruvate kinase but because
this reaction is so strongly exothermic
I cannot go the other way the reverse
step is irreversible the mini network
that we've just navigated with all of
its steps some of which require ATP was
done in order to bypass the irreversible
pyruvate kinase reaction we have just
worked very hard to move atoms from
pyruvate alanine and lactate into the
cytosol where those atoms are now
packaged as pepra phosphoenolpyruvate
now let's focus on fossil enol pyruvate
and let it flow backward through the
reverse of glycolysis all the way up to
the next irreversible step at fructose 1
6 bisphosphate all of the steps between
faso enol pyruvate and fructose 1 6
bisphosphate are common to both lou
Coony
Genesis and glycolysis fructose 1 6
bisphosphate cannot be converted to
fructose 6-phosphate by reversal of the
pfk 1 phosphofructokinase 1 enzymatic
step that step is to thermodynamically
irreversible consequently nature
invented fructose 1 6 bisphosphate ace
we saw the mechanism of that enzyme
earlier in the lecture it allows the
conversion of fructose 1 6 bisphosphate
to fructose 6-phosphate then the
molecule continues upstream to form
glucose 6-phosphate and once again a
gluconeogenic specific enzyme
glucose-6-phosphatase will convert
glucose 6-phosphate into glucose lastly
the manufacturer glucose is exported
from the cell by the glucose transporter
so while it was a long passage the
carbon Abin atoms from alanine and
lactate have traveled all the way to
glucose and then the glucose has been
sent out of the cell that is their
carbons are now incorporated into the
molecules of glucose that go off from
the liver and renal cortex to organs
that need glucose to meet their energy
needs or their needs for the glucose
skeleton for other biochemical purposes
gluconeogenic precursor 3 is glutamate
this is the amino acid equivalent of the
organic acid alpha ketoglutarate so look
at alpha ketoglutarate at about 3
o'clock on the TCA cycle you'll see
glutamate precursor 3 being deaminated
by a PLP mediated process this converts
glutamate into alpha ketoglutarate most
of the carbons of the alpha
ketoglutarate will then move clockwise
around the TCA cycle and end up at about
9 o'clock as malate then as we saw for
precursors 1 & 2 the malate will be
exported from the mitochondrion and next
most of its atoms will find their way
back to glucose just as we saw with
alanine and lactate earlier precursor 4
is aspartic acid aspartic acid is the
amino acid equivalent of oxaloacetate
aspartate is deaminated into
oxaloacetate which enters the glial
gluconeogenic pathway at about 10
o'clock
on the TCA cycle at this point the
oxaloacetate formed from aspartate joins
the oxaloacetate made from alanine and
lactate precursors 1 and 2 and continues
all the way back to glucose
gluconeogenic precursor 5 comes from odd
chain fatty acids which are depicted way
over on the right of the metabolic map
as we've seen our chain fatty acids are
catabolized into 3 carbon compounds such
as propia Neel coenzyme a one of the
carboxyl Aizaz propionyl coenzyme a
carboxylase will add a carbon to this
three carbon molecule then methylmalonyl
coenzyme a mutase in its partner epimer
a's will complete conversion of the
three carbon propane Eelco a to the 4
carbon product succinylcholine which
will then integrate into the TCA cycle
succinylcholine ma enters at about five
o'clock on the TCA cycle the carbons
then flow clockwise to malate just as
we've seen before most of those carbons
will flow all the way back to be built
into glucose gluconeogenic precursors
indicated by number six are the amino
acids isoleucine methionine and valine
these are once again way over on the
right-hand side of the figure these
amino acids are also converted to
protein Ocoee and just as with the odd
chain fatty acids they will be converted
into succinylcholine ma then their atoms
follow the pathway all the way back to
glucose as we've seen now several times
slightly to the left of center you'll
see gluconeogenesis or number seven
which is glycerol glycerol is a try
alcohol produced from the metabolism of
complex lipids it derives from the three
carbon backbone that holds fatty acids
and phosphates by ester linkages
glycerol is first phosphorylated to
glycerol 3-phosphate and then that
product is oxidized to dihydroxyacetone
phosphate we've seen this chemistry
before from DHAP or dihydroxyacetone
phosphate the molecules flow leftward on
the chart to fructose 1 6 bisphosphate
and then they continue on through
gluconeogenesis
to glucose lastly precursor
number eight is ribose we mainly obtain
ribose from our diet in the next lecture
I'm going to cover the pentose phosphate
pathway in this pathway ribose from the
diet will enter what I call the
quote-unquote carbon scrambling phase of
the pentose phosphate pathway ribose
goes into the carbon scrambling phase of
the pathway and gap or glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate and fructose 6-phosphate
come out both of these molecules gap and
fructose 6-phosphate
will flow from right to left all the way
to glucose in the pathway that I've
drawn out in panel C hence ribose is a
good gluconeogenic precursor let me
summarize the functional dimensions of
the gluconeogenic pathway from a high
altitude imagine that overnight as you
sleep you're not consuming any food
consequently at some point your blood
sugar is going to drop your
gluconeogenic organs the liver and renal
cortex will sense this drop in blood
sugar and turn on the hatched line
pathways we've seen above in order to
take readily available non carbohydrate
precursors such as lactate alanine
ribose and so on and convert those non
carbohydrate precursors into glucose the
liver in riedle cortex will then send
that glucose out into the bloodstream to
client organs for example the brain red
blood cells and renal medulla ultimately
these client organs will be able to rely
on a constant level of glucose that in a
nutshell is the role of the
gluconeogenic pathway